epic day iconic day moving offices hey
you getting ready look how much [ __ ]
they're still here look at rowdy
I'm gonna miss 12 so much have you ready
for Hudson Yards are you guys seem to be
working really hard in the move
guys I want my los office to be awesome
on Monday that's it he actually Jordan
brought that up today he's like Tyler
wants to get in the lip I go I love that
people think it's like some sort of like
random thing you do know I I got to tell
you I could never work out if I didn't
have a person and what I did today
yes again I couldn't pay you you
couldn't pay me to do Mary more white
pants yeah dude on a very serious note
let's get you hung like to bring the
crew like bring for Andy we're gonna
work out of there look I get it okay I
want my office to be awesome on Monday I
have 44 people on my team and I'm gonna
walk in monday and I'm gonna go into
like a box with nothing to set up like
my office should be like [ __ ]
pristine I should have [ __ ] work it
in the fiddling like I should walk in
like it should be like it should be done
already it should be gorgeous like I'm a
CEO this [ __ ] company I'm gonna walk
in like a piece of [ __ ]
guys I want my office office to be
awesome on Monday and I feel like it's
not going to be and I feel like there's
74 people on my team and so like can we
figure this out like but wait I check
these things but you guys gonna went
through his stuff have you fun nobody
that you think good for me no that's
good stuff hey guys I feel like I do all
the good stuff Emily you think it's
appropriate that my office is gonna be
[ __ ] on Monday like nothing good was
gonna happen I was gonna walk into no no
in theory but like not like set up no
there's nothing in there Emily I paid
for those views Tyler tell the truth cuz
you always do that's what I love about
you always say yes and would the office
be unbelievably cozy on Monday had I not
said something unbelievably I feel like
it was gonna now be cozy but I trust I
trust if Tyler doesn't
so I guess I gotta go with it sorry
you're sorry
Hey look at this sky sky
you're on periscope you need to know
you're obviously varying charges this
big move are we under control are you
ready you got this
sure look at rowdy put together seven
boxes already I'm impressed
my office hey Linds good sup guys this
is it huh yo what's that the hell are
you talking about I mean everybody's
getting a little bit high I agree
everybody's getting a little too over
they go ahead I guess yeah I mean like
very great I know I'll be the most
famous person in the world but I'm not
yet sup guys hey guys hi hey you getting
ready ready
packing yeah sup dude look how much [ __ ]
there's still here
is she wearing a bill shirt you know
what scared me
you know what scared me your bill shirt
do you think it's a good idea to wear to
bill shirt and these parts that's a
strategic mistake that's right I'm just
going in the HR software no big deal
just got to leave a comment
it's like staggeringly better it's so
what when people accept that I'm like
[ __ ] when the ones that are sick close
to the window everybody makes oh it's
all light it's all well and they just
kind of brains difference of views the
water it's game to this I'm also super
into like we're there and we're going to
watch the whole [ __ ] thing get bill
yeah smart
yeah Matty D look at this crew it's like
this is like a family reunion this is
where you sit oh yeah big my team kicked
me out so you ready from 12 I'm 12 he
ready for Hudson Yards did you see it
you went eats I got to see like the
seating arrangements but did you
physically go yeah what's happening
Pavle how you oh good
large well I figured I'd come and see 12
you know I'm gonna miss 12 so much we
hooked up once I have them once with 12
core that's a really good screensaver
brother you might be up for a promotion
I'm firing a Buffalo Bills fan on 15
that's it so I just went on for 16 15
and 12 with Tyler and the Iraq and I
will never see these floors okay hello
I'm coming back because my flights
delayed I'm gonna bang out the last
episode of askgaryvee in its original
location
on this episode we do the last episode
ever of the askgaryvee show in this
office you guys don't seem to be
contributing or you guys seem to be
working really hard in the move got it
we just started the moves oh god can you
call him find out what the [ __ ] is going
on [ __ ] me oh [ __ ] me as polite pisses
me off so bad what are we doing with
this [ __ ] flight you just cancel the
flight out right
they push me tomorrow there's a major
storm I guess in Nashville so
everything's getting so my flights been
flat-out canceled rebook for tomorrow
look you know we'll hang here for 10-15
minutes maybe there might be a chance
we're going back and my daily view some
fool captures the highs and the lows of
high-class business Bravo's listen not
every plan works out the way you think
it's going to so Nashville don't worry I
will never let anybody down
unfortunately tomorrow morning I have a
5:45 flight middle seat economy
connecting it's me a tough day tomorrow
epic day iconic day moving offices for
the one two three four five six office
buddy media conference room sunshine
Suites 23rd Street 24th Street 24th
Street 27th Street 24th Street and now
Hudson Yards backs it back to where we
started West Side